millions and millions of people around
the world realize that bitcoin is the
most decentralized computing network
that's ever been created and that
decentralization leads to an incredible
amount of security no one has been able
to hack the bitcoin network now bitcoin
and its promise from the white paper
being published on october 31st 2008 is
that bitcoin would become electronic
peer-to-peer cash now that promise is
still alive and well today but over time
people have come together and realized
we cannot scale bitcoin just at the
layer one that layer one is built for
security but it isn't necessarily the
cheapest or fastest to send value to
someone else in the world if we go back
and we look at the us dollar system we
know that money is built in layers gold
super secure but not very easy to
transact gold may serve as a great store
of value but it wasn't necessarily the
best payment rails nor the best medium
of exchange so naturally we built a
second layer on top of gold in the form
of paper currency or paper claims on
that gold eventually we built many
layers on top including credit and
electronic money now if we come back to
bitcoin what we find is that layer one
is secure just like gold was secure as
well
but now we are building a layer two the
equivalent of those paper currencies on
top of gold but it's called the
lightning network and what it allows you
to do is send bitcoin actual bitcoin to
anyone else in the world instantaneously
and nearly for free this peer-to-peer
system that has been built as a layer
two on top of bitcoin is allowing for
the full promise of bitcoin as a
peer-to-peer cash electronic system to
come into reality
the bitcoin network has already grown to
immense size over the last 13 years the
lightning network's white paper was
published in 2016 and the lightning
network went into beta in 2018 and in
four short years what we have seen is
that the lightning network continues to
hit all-time highs in network capacity
nodes continue to grow and the
peer-to-peer network continues to cover
more and more of the world ultimately
the lightning network will be a major
piece of infrastructure as bitcoin
scales globally and becomes money that
is used by anyone
the instantaneous and free transactions
that are provided by that layer 2
technology will create an inflection
point in adoption and also make it much
more usable for everyday people to spend
bitcoin to send bitcoin and to simply
move economic value around the world
bitcoins layer 2 the lightning network
is on an absolute tear it is a great
sign that regardless of the price of
bitcoin there is more building happening
there's more adoption happening and
ultimately there's more utility being
realized by millions of people around
the world the layer two of bitcoin the
lightning network it is eating the world
and over time i expect that there will
be billions of people using lightning to
send economic value to their friends
their family their colleagues their
customers
and
anyone they want without having to rely
on a trusted third party and without
having to use fiat currency that's not
backed by anything hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time